SIXTY SECONDS.
IS THAT RIGHT.
THE SENATE TRANSPORTATION
COMMITTEE WILL COME TO ORDER A
GOOD MORNING IN RESPONSE TO THE
COVERT NINETEEN EMERGENCY AND
TO PROTECT THE PUBLIC
LEGISLATORS AND EMPLOYEES WE
MUST LIMIT NON ESSENTIAL
GATHERINGS AND HERE TO SOCIAL
DISTANCING AND FCE COVERING
GUIDELINES IN COMPLIANCE WITH
THOSE ORDERS THE SENATE HAS
MADE NECESSARY ADJUSTMENTS TO
NORMAL PRACTICES IN ORDER TO
ENSURE THAT THE PUBLIC
CONTINUES TO HAVE ACCESS TO THE
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS. TO ALLOW
THE PUBLIC ACCESS WE HAVE
ADMITTED MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
TO TWO HEARING ROOMS TO THE
EXTENT THAT SOCIAL DISTANCING
REQUIREMENTS ALLOW AND WILL BE
USING A TELECONFERENCE SERVICE
FOR THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH
TO TESTIFY TODAY FOR ALL
INDIVIDUALS WHO WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY AND PROVIDE PUBLIC
COMMENT THE PARTICIPANT TOLL
FREE NUMBER AND ACCESS CODE IS
POSTED ON OUR COMMITTEE WEBSITE
IT WILL BE DISPLAYED ON THE
SCREEN AND I WILL ANNOUNCE IT
NOW. TODAY'S PARTICIPANT NUMBER
IS. 877-226-8152 ACCESS CODE.
NINE ONE ONE EIGHT NINE TWO
EIGHT. FOR DETAILED
INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW THE
TELECONFERENCES TO WORKS PLEASE
REFER TO THE SENATE AND OUR
COMMITTEE WEBSITE WHEN WE MOVED
TO PUBLIC COMMENT YOU WILL BE
PROMPTED BY A MODERATOR. TO
DIAL ONE THEN ZERO FOR SUPPORT
pAND OPPOSITION. PRESS THIS ONLY
ONE TIME AND WAIT PATIENTLY FOR
AN OPERATOR TO SIGN YOU A LINE.
THIS CAN BE A SHORT WAIT ONCE
YOU RECEIVE YOUR LINE NUMBER.
YOU WILL WAIT IN THE QUEUE FOR
THE MODERATOR TO CALL YOUR LINE
NUMBER AT THAT TIME YOU'LL BE
MUTED ON MUTED. EXCUSE ME AND
YOU ARE NOW READY TO ADDRESS
THE COMMITTEE. PLEASE NOTE THAT
IN ORDER. FOR US TO HEAR YOU
CLEARLY AND AVOID CAUSES
FEEDBACK YOU MUST MEET THE
DEVICE YOU'RE WATCHING THE
HEARING ON PRIOR TO GIVING
TESTIMONY OVER THE PHONE. IT IS
IMPORTANT THAT WE HEAR FROM YOU
AND WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE. I WILL ALSO MAINTAIN
DECORUM DURING THE HEARING AS
IS USTOMARY. AND ANY
INDIVIDUAL WHO IS DISRUPTIVE
MAY BE REMOVED FROM THE REMOTE
MEETING SERVICE OR HAVE THEIR
CONNECTIONS MUTED. WHILE EVERY
EFFORT HAS BEEN MADE. TO
STREAMLINE THE HEARING PROCESS
AND CONDUCT OUR HEARINGS. IN AS
CLOSE TO THE MATTER AS IS
CUSTOMARY. THERE MAY BE SOME
LAG TIMES FOR PARTICIPANTS WHO
ARE ADJUSTING TO THE NEW USE OF
ONLINE TOOLS OR TECHNOLOGIES
SO. THAT'S ALL PLEASE BE
RESPECTFUL AND PATIENT- SO
INTERESTED PARTIES CAN BE
HEARD. NOW LET'S. GET STARTED
WITH THE BUSINESS OF THE
COMMITTEE BY ESTABLISHING A-
QUORUM.A CONSULTANT CAN YOU
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. SENATOR
GONZALES HERE IT'S ALWAYS HERE
FATES. IT'S PRESENT ALAN. MARCH
ELEVENTH MARCH LETTER HERE
BACKER. CORTESE DOLLY. DOT.
MCGUIRE YOU'RE REQUIRED HERE
MELINDA'S. MAN. NEWMAN NEWMAN
HERE WILL BE ABLE. RUBIO
PRESENT SKINNER. HUMBERT WHY
CASKEY. WELCOME WILL PRESENT.
WELL SHORT OF A QUORUM MANAGER
OKAY WOULD YOU LIKE ME TO CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS YES PLEASE
MAKE CAN YOU CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS BUSINESS CONSULTANT.
ALAN BETTER- BECKER HERE- DAISY
CORTESE HERE DOLLY. DOT
MELINDA'S. MAN MAN HERE SKINNER.
NUMBER. WHY CASKET HERE'S MY
CALCULATOR WE HAVE A QUORUM
THANK YOU MR CONSULTANT SO-
MEMBERS FIRST WE HAVE THE
CONSENT CALENDAR WE ONLY HAVE
TWO ITEMS ON THE AGENDA THE
REST ARE ON CONSENT THAT'S THE
FOUR EIGHT ITEMS TOTAL SO THE
CONSENT CALENDAR THESE ARE THE
BILLS CURRENTLY ON CONSENT A.
B. TWO THIRTY TWO BY GALLAGHER
EIGHTY THREE OH TWO WARD AB
FIVE NINETY ONE BY THE UP TO
THE LEFT EIGHTY SEVEN EIGHTY
FOUR QUIRK EIGHTY SEVEN NINETY
EIGHT RAMEAU'S AB ELEVEN FIFTY
SEVEN LEADS- DOES ANYONE HAVE
AN OBJECTION TO ANY OF THE
ITEMS ON THE CONSENT SO MOVED.
THANK YOU SENATOR WILL BE
SHIPPED THAT MOVE BY SENATOR
WELK CONSULTANCIES. COLOR ON
THE CONSENT CALENDAR. ON THE
CONSENT. CONSULTANTS HI
CONSOLES I BASE HI BATES HI
ELLEN. ARCHULETA ARE MARCH
LETTER HI BETTER WRITE BETTER
HI CORTESE I GOOD DAY TO YOU HI
DOLLY HI KELLY HI DOT. IF YOU
ARE REALLY WHERE I WILL END. IN
I WHEN I WENT ALL RIGHT NEWMAN
HI WILL BE ABLE. RIGHT RUBIO I
SKINNER. NUMBER I'M HI MIKE HI
BYE CASKEY HOW WILL HI WELL I.
THE BOATS OKAY THANK YOU LEAVE
THE ROLE- OPEN FOR AT MAN THANK
YOU MISTER CAN NOW TAKE UP THE
AND FOR ORDER THE FIRST WE HAVE
IS AB THREE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
FONG WELCOME MR FONG THANK YOU
FOR BEING HERE WE HAVE TWO
IMPORTANT **** SAFETY MEASURES
THIS IS THE FIRST ONE S YOU
MAY. PRESENT YOUR BILL ON
EIGHTY THREE THANK YOU. I THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR AND SENATORS.
TODAY I AM PROUD TO PRESENT A
B. THREE. I FIRST LIKE TO OFFER
AMENDMENTS TO ADD SOMETHING
MEMBERS FRIEDMAN AND SYRIAN AND
SENATOR RUBIO. AS CO AUTHORS
AND I WANT TO THANK THEM FOR
THEIR PARTNERSHIP. I ALSO WANT
TO THANK THE COMMITTEE STAFF
FOR THEIR DILIGENT ANALYSIS OF
A B. THREE. THIS BILL AIMS TO
CURB ILLEGAL STREET RACING. BY
STOPPING IT AT ITS SOURCE. THE
MOTOR VEHICLE EXHIBITION OF
SPEED. THE EXHIBITION SPEED IS
MOST COMMONLY RECOGNIZED AS
SITE SHOWS. THAT INCLUDED
DRIFTING PERFORMING STUNTS
DOUGHNUTS OR OTHER ACTIVITIES.
DONE AT DANGEROUS SPEEDS TO
SHOW OFF TO A CROWD IN OUR
STREETS AND INTERSECTIONS. AS A
COVERT NINETEEN SHUT DOWNS
CLEAR THE STREETS. CALIFORNIA
HAS SEEN A STAGGERINGSPIKE
THIS RECKLESS ACTIVITY. LEADING
TO DEVASTATINGRACKS AND
SENSELESS DEATHS IN OUR
COMMUNITIES. LAST YEAR ALONE.
THE CHP RESPONDED TO OVER
TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND CALLS
INVOLVING THE EXHIBITION OF
SPEED AND STREET RACING.
REPORTER AND REPORTED. A NEARLY
3100% SURGE IN MOTOR VEHICLE
EXHIBITION SPEED CITATIONS OVER
THE PAST FIVE YEARS. BUT SADLY.
NOT ALL EXHIBITION IS BE CASES
IN WHICH A PATIENT'S. SALAD
NEARLY 47% OF. THESE CRASHES
RESULT IN INJURY. 42% RESULT IN
PROPERTY DAMAGE. 11% RESULT IN
DEATH. IT'S BEHAVIOR ARE.
CLAIMS INNOCENT. INPUTS CAN BE.
BIKERS PEDESTRIANS AND LAW
FORCE AT FATAL RISK. I'M SURE
WE ALL KNOW OF TRAGIC CRASHES
IN SITUATIONS IN OUR OWN
DISTRICTS AND NEIGHBORHOODS.
THE STARTLING REALITY IS THAT.
WE FIND. THE TRAGIC STREET
RACING STORIES IN THE
NEWSPAPER. EVERY SINGLE DAY OF
THE WEEK. EVERY SINGLE ONE OF
THESE CRASHES ARE PREVENTABLE.
I WANT TO BE CLEAR THAT EIGHTY
THREE DOES NOT CREATE A NEW
CRIME. BUT RATHER BRINGS PARITY
TO EXISTING RECKLESS DRIVING
CRIMESAND GRANTS THE COURT THE
DISCRETION. TO TAKE ACTION ON
SPEED EXHIBITION AND SUCH AS
BEFORE THEY RESULT IN
DEVASTATION. REFORMING RECKLESS
SPEED STANDS AND STREET RACES
ARE EQUALLY DANGEROUS CRIMES
IMPOSED AN EQUAL RISK TO OUR
ROADS AND COMMUNITIES. HOWEVER
HOWEVER ONLY A CONVICTION FOR
THE LATTER CAN RESULT IN A
SUSPENDED LICENSE. AB THREE
CLOSES THAT LOOPHOLE. AB THREE
HAS RECEIVED BIPARTISAN SUPPORT
TO THE ASSEMBLY. HAS SUPPORTED
BY MOTHERS AGAINST DRUNK
DRIVING STATEWIDE LAW
ENFORCEMENT. AND VICTIMS RIGHTS
GROUPS AND LOCAL GOVERNMENT.
BUT THAT WOULD BE TODAY IS
THERE CANDLER CENTER FOR. WHO
FIRST HAND EXPERIENCE
DEVASTATING IMPACTS OF ILLEGAL
STREET RACING ACTIVITY BACK
HOME IN BAKERSFIELD. I URGE I
BUILT THANK YOU SIMPLY MEMBER
FARM WE APPRECIATE THE
PRESENTATION AND NOW WE WILL GO
TO YOUR PRIMARY WITNESS AND
SUPPORT SARAH CANDLER- YOU HAVE
THREE MINUTES SO YOU CAN GO
RIGHT AHEAD AND SHE'S HERE IN
THE GALLERY. THANK YOU FOR
BEING WITH US. GOOD MORNING MY
NAME IS DEREK TAYLOR AND I'M
FROM BAKERSFIELD CALIFORNIA. IN
NOVEMBER OF TWENTY NINETEEN I
WOULD SEE THE MOST TERRIFYING
INCONSEQUENTIAL PHONE CALL THAT
CHANGED MY FAMILY'S LIFE
FOREVER. MY MOM HE CAN THEY
WERE STRUCK BY A DRIVER THAT
LOST CONTROL OF THEIR VEHICLE
DURING AN ILLEGAL STREET RACE.
THIS TERRIFYING CALL QUICKLY
TURNED DEVASTATING WHEN MY MOM
LOST HER LIFE SHORTLY AFTER.
HER AT THE SCENE. I COULD HAVE
NEVER PREPARED MYSELF FOR THE
OVERWHELMING GRIEF. THIS CRASH
THAT BROUGHT MY FAMILY. THE
CRASHING WAS HORROR. I WILL
NEVER FORGET THINGS OF. HOW
MUCH DAMAGE STREET RACING
INSIDE SHOWS CAN CAUSE MY MOM'S
CAR WAS MANGLED AND THE DAMAGE
WAS SO SIGNIFICANT THAT THE
FIRST RESPONDERS HOW TO USE THE
JAWS OF LIFE. COULD OPEN TO BE
ABLE TO REACH MY MOM. MY MOM IS
THE ONLY PERSON IN IRAQ THAT
LOST HER LIFE THAT DAY. BUT
THEY TRY TO DO THIS SENSELESS
PROCESS COULD HAVE GONE SO MUCH
FURTHER. NOT ONLY DID THE
VEHICLES RACING HAVE SEVERAL
PEOPLE IN THE CAR BUT MY MOM
WAS HIT ON A SUNDAY AFTERNOON
ON A MAIN STREET IN BAKERSFIELD
RIGHT OUTSIDE OF THE BUSY MALL.
AND CLOSE WALK TO A POPULAR
PARK IN CHURCH. INDIVIDUALS
PARTICIPATING IN SIDESHOWS AND
STREET RACING DO OT THINK
ABOUT THE DEVASTATION THEIR
ACTIONS CAN BRAIN. INJURY
THING- PERFORMING SENSE AT SUCH
HIGH SPEEDS IT BECOMES NEARLY
IMPOSSIBLE TO STOP. YOUR CAR
WHEN YOU LOSE CONTROL. DESPITE
COUNTLESS HEADLINES DURING.-LIKE MINE THE BIGGER SO POLICE
DEPARTMENT REPORTED OVER SIX
THOUSAND CALLS INVOLVING.
EXPEDITION OF SPEED AND STREET
RACING LAST YEAR ALONE.
FAMILIES ACROSS THE STATE ARE
EXPERIENCING THE SAME LIVING
NIGHTMARE MY FAMILY FELT EVERY
SINGLE DAY. EVERY SINGLE ONE OF
THESE CRASHES IT HAS
DEVASTATING IMPACTS ON VICTIMS
FAMILIES. AND EVERY SINGLE
STREET RACING CRASH IS
PREVENTABLE AB THREE PROVIDES
LAWS. LAW ENFORCEMENT WITH AN
ADDITIONAL TOOL TO PREVENT
THESE TRAGEDIES BEFORE THEY
HAPPEN. THANK YOU SOMEBODY MAN
FEMME FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP ON
THIS IMPORTANT ISSUE. AND THEY
GET TO THE COMMITTEE FOR YOUR
SUPPORT OF EIGHTY THREE. I
RESPECTFULLY RESPECTFULLY. ASK
FOR YOUR IDOLS. THANK YOU MS
CAN LEARN AND- YOU COULD AGAIN
TO YOUR MOTHER AND WE THANK YOU
FOR BEING HERE AS WELL- OKAY WE
HAVE. COMPLETED THE PRIMARIES
THE WITNESS AND SUPPORT ARE
THERE ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT OF EIGHTY THREE IN THE
GALLERY. OKAY SEE NONE- ARE
THERE ANY WITNESSES IN ROOM ONE
TWELVE IN SUPPORT OF EIGHTY
THREE. WE SEE NONE I'M NOT
SEEING ANY SO WE'LL MOVE TO THE
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE- MR OR
MADAM MADAM MODERATOR IF YOU
WOULD PLEASE PROMPT ANY
INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO TESTIFY.
IN SUPPORT OF AB THREE. ON THE
TELECONFERENCE ARTISTS.
MODERATOR MODERATORS DO WE HAVE
ANYONE ON THE LINE IN SUPPORT
OF AB THREE. IF YOU WISH TO
COMMENT ON AB THREE PLEASE
PRESS ONE TO ZERO AT THIS TIME.
SHE. IT'S A SMALL I GATHER MY
NUMBER. OKAY IT WAS FIRST COME
IT COMES FROM THE LINE FIFTEEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS CORY
CELLS- ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE SHERIFFS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT
COMMENT PLEASE. I LIKE TO GO TO
LINE FOURTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO GOOD MORNING EVERYONE MY
NAME IS KATIE SAGAL AND I AM
THE FOUNDER OF TWEET THEY THINK
KILLED I FIND IT TO BE PICKED
UP AND I THOUGHT ABOUT IT
CANNOT POSSIBLY BE TRUE
DEPRESSED SIXTEEN YEARS OLD
BACK IN. TWO THOUSAND THIRTEEN.
THE NAME OF MY OWN. SEKOLAH
JUST WAIT TO KILL. HIM FOR OPEN
UP PAYMENT IF YOU CAN BEGIN
WITH FOR CALLING PHONE THERE'S-
A TOTAL OF TWELVE. SUPPORT
EIGHTY TWO. LET BOBBY. THE
CHOPPER. ALBUM HELP ONE PERSON.
PUBLIC SCHOOL. PRINCIPAL
BECAUSE THE POINT OF FIVE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
FOR YOUR CALL NOW COMMENT
PLEASE. MEXICO LINE SEVEN
PLEASE GO- MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF COMMITTEE KIM CHANG
WITH THE AUTO CLUB SOUTHERN.
AND WE SIT THIS BILL AND URGE
AN IPHONE. THANK YOU NEXT
COMMENT. AND WE HAVE NO ONE
ELSE IN Q. IT THIS TIME. OKAY
THANK YOU MY SO WE WILL THIS
PROCESS FOR ANY WOULD. IN
OPPOSITE SO WE START WITH A
PRIMARY WITNESS IN OPPOSITION
KATHY SURE WITH THE ACLU-
WHO'LL USE THE CO HOST LINES A
MODERATOR CAN WE ENSURE THAT-
KATHY SURE IS ON THE LINE
CURRENTLY. IN OPPOSITION. YEAH
CAT IS ONLINE AND HER LINE IS
OPEN. THANK YOU MR PLANTED GOOD
MORNING GOOD MORNING MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS- KHAKI SHIRT
FOR ACLU CALIFORNIA ACTION. WE
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE EIGHTY
THREE. FIRST LET ME START BY
SAYING HOW SORRY I AM FOR.
CAMPERS LOST ON AND WHAT SHE'S
HAD TO GO THROUGH- WE ALL
CERTAINLY SHARE THE GOAL OF-
PREVENTING INCIDENTS LIKE THE
ONE THAT THE CHILDREN EITHER.
UNFORTUNATELY WE DON'T BELIEVE
THAT THIS BILL WILL DO ANYTHING
TO CARTER'S. APPREHENSION CALL.
IT LAW PROVIDES SERIOUS PENALTY
FOR THE WHO ENGAGE IN THAT. OF
SPEED AS PART OF THIS FIGHT OR
OR OTHER LINES. LAWMAKERS
VEHICLE EXHIBITION OF SPEED.
PUNISHABLE BY TERM OF TO NINETY
DAYS A FINE OF UP TO FIVE
HUNDRED OR BOTH WITH HIGHER
THAT THEY- WHEN THE INTERNET
RESULT IN OR- DAMAGE IT IS WE
OFFER. IN THE EUROPEAN PEOPLE
VIA CALL I MEAN HOW FOR UP. TO
THIRTY. I LICENSES AND TO THE-
FOR THE BEHAVIOUR WILL NOT.
DRIVE FROM THE IN IT. TO THE-
IT'S IT WILL BECOME MORE MORE
HEARD FOR THOSE WHO TRY TO MOVE
ON THEIR LIFE AFTER AFTER THAT
KIND OF. ACTION STANDING IN THE
WAY OF BEING ABLE TO DRIVE
LEGALLY TO ATTEND SCHOOL TO
TAKE OTHER THAN THEIR HOUSEHOLD
TO THEIR WORKPLACES ARE TAKEN
CELL. OR OTHER FAMILY MEMBERS
TO MEDICAL. BUT NOTHING IN A
THREE. ON THE JUDGE TO TAKE THE
FACTORS INTO IT WHEN THE-
WHETHER TO SEND SOMEONE LIKE.
PILING ON YOU CAN. DOES NOTHING
REDUCE BUT CAN A RIPPLE EFFECT
THAT HARMED INDIVIDUAL AND
ENTIRE COMMUNITIES. WE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
NOTEBOOK. THANK YOU MAKE SURE
THAT COMPLETES- THE PRIMARY
OPPOSITION IN- UP. OPPOSITION
TO AB THREE SO NOW WE WILL GO
TO ANY WITNESSES IN THE GALLERY.
IN OPPOSITION TO AB THREE. C.
NINE ANY WITNESSES IN ROOM ONE
TWELVE IN OPPOSITION AT EIGHTY
THREE C. NINE. SO NOW WE'LL GO
BACK TO THE TELECONFERENCE LINE
ANY WITNESSES ON THE LINE IN
OPPOSITION TO AB THREE MISTER
MODERATOR. AND ONCE AGAIN IF
YOU HAVE A COMMENT PLEASE PRESS
ONE TO ZERO AT THIS TIME. I
THINK WE HAVE A COMMENT FROM
LINE FOURTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
YEAH I CAN HEAR THE INITIAL TWO
WEEKS IN JAIL WITHOUT PROVIDING
PATIENT HAVE A TECHNICIAN
PROGRAM BUT WE THE GENTLEMAN
BACK TWENTY TWENTY ONE.
TEENAGER IN. NO INFORMATION BUT
THE LACK OF THREE ON THAT AT
THE TIED. BOB AND PAUL I'M VERY
WELL. YEAH THE CARD UNTIL AWAY
THAT'S WHY WE ARE COMMITTED
MA'AM IF WE HAVE YOUR AT YOUR
NAME AND ORGANIZATION AND THIS
IS THE LAW THIS THE TIME WE'RE
TAKING OPPOSITE TO A. THREE ALL
I KNOW. OKAY THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR YOUR AND LAST-
MODERATE IS THERE ANYONE ELSE
THE GIVEN UP. TO AB THREE.
THERE'S NO ONE ELSE IN QUEUE AT
THIS TIME. OKAY THANK YOU SO
WE'VE COMPLETED SUPPORT AND
OPPOSITION WILL TAKE IT BACK TO
MEMBERS FOR ANY QUESTIONS I SEE
SENATOR RUBIO FIRST. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR- I DO STAND IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL AND ALSO
AS A CO AUTHOR TO THIS BILL.
YOU KNOW I WANT TO BE-
EXTREMELY SENSITIVE TO THE
CONCERNS OF THE ACLU ODD
THEY'RE RIPPED THEIR BALLOT.
YOU KNOW ALL OF US HERE WANT TO
DO WHAT WE CAN TO HELP OUR
YOUTH ESPECIALLY AFTER. ON
GETTING INTO TROUBLE MOVE ON
WITH THEIR LIVES IT DIDN'T DO
WHAT WE CAN. TO HELP FIX THEIR
SITUATION. BUT WHEN I OF. THE
YOUNG LADY THAT JUST TESTIFIED
ABOUT LOSING HER MOTHER. THE
FAMILIES OF THE VICTIMS ARE NOT
ABLE TO MOVE ON SO I ALSO HAVE
TO BE MINDFUL OF THE VICTIMS
THAT ARE LEFT BEHIND. YOU KNOW
WHAT THESE TRAGIC ACCIDENTS NOT
ONLY IS. YOU KNOW I SHE STATED
YOU KNOW HER HER PERSONALLY
MEDIA FAMILY LEFT DEALING WITH
SUCH TRAGEDY BUT EXTENDED
FAMILY SO MANY FAMILIES ARE
IMPACTED BY. BY THESE TYPES OF
ACCIDENTS AND AGAIN AND EVEN
THOUGHI DO UNDERSTAND AND HAVE
SENSITIVITY TO THE OPPOSITION'S
CONCERN I THINK IT'S SOMETHING
THAT WE NEED TO PUT IN PLACE.
AND ENSURE THAT IT LEAVES THE
VICTIMS CAN FEEL CONFIDENT THAT
WE ARE ALSO LOOKING OUT FOR
THEIR LIVES AND THEIR- THEIR
CIRCUMSTANCE AND WITH THAT I
ASKED FOR AND I WILL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SENATOR RUBIO SENATOR
WHAT HOUSEKEEPING MANAGER I'D
LIKE TO ASK THE AUTHOR WHO IS
GOING TO BE INCLUDED IN
ALLOWING FOR SUSPENSIONS WHEN
SOMEBODY'S CAUGHT IN A SPEECH
CONTEST ASSIST STAFF REPORT
POINTS. OUT AND AS THE
OPPOSITION IS SAID. THE
EXHIBITION SPEED IS THE LESS
AND OFFENSE OR ALLOW OFFENSE.
SO WHEN THESE PEOPLE ARE
CHARGED IN BAKERSFIELD OR LOS
ANGELES OR SAN JOSE THEY'RE
CHARGED WITH SPEECH CONTEST. AN
EXHIBITION OF SPEED DOWN. I CAN
SEE SOMEBODY SAYING WELL I WAS
A CONTEST BECAUSE IT THIS THIS
THIS CLEVER LAWYER BUT THEY CAN
STILL BE VIOLATING THE
EXHIBITION SPEED WHICH INCLUDES
THE NINETY DAY. LICENSE
SUSPENSION SO HOW DOES IT WORK
THE OTHER WAY MADAM CHAIR HOW
CAN YOU. BE IN A SPEECH CONTEST
BUT NOT. EXHIBITING SPEED IN
YOUR IN THE VEHICLE HOW WOULD
YOU HELP WORSE AT COLE PORTER
PEOPLE THAT WE'RE GOING TO
CATCH. THE AUTHOR COULD ADDRESS
THAT. SURE THANK YOU SENATOR
AKOWSKI AN ASSEMBLY MEMBER
PHONE DO YOU WANT TO DRESS THAT
NOW OR IN YOUR CLOTHES. I CAN I
CAN DO EITHER WAY WHATEVER
WHATEVER THE RIGHT ANSWER I
WOULD SAY THAT THAT. THAT HOW
THE EXHIBITION IS SPEED IS
DEFINED AS A PERSON ENGAGING
AND EXHIBITIONS B. WHERE HE OR
SHE XCELERATED DRIVES AT A RATE
OF SPEED THAT IS DANGEROUS AND
UNSAFE IN ORDER TO SHOW OFF. OR
MAKE AN IMPRESSION ON SOMEONE
ELSE THAT IS DISTINCTLY
DIFFERENT FROM MY SPEECH
CONTEST WE ARE RACING AGAINST
THE CLOCK. OR I GUESS ANOTHER
VEHICLE SO THAT THE BUT WHEN
YOU PARTICIPATE IN A SIDE SHOW
YOU MAY NOT BE MAYBE LEADING UP
TO A SPEECH CONTEST BUT YOU
NAME ME NOT BE PARTICIPATING IN
THIS BECAUSE AS PER SE. SO WE
WOULD SAY THAT BOTH OF THOSE-
ACTIVITIES AND BEHAVIORS ARE
ARE EQUALLY DANGEROUS AND THAT
AND THAT'S WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO
CREATE SOME PARITY. IN TERMS
OF- THE OPPOSITION FROM THE SO
YOU WE HAVE SPOKEN WITH THE CEO
AND THE ASSEMBLY TRANSPORTATION
BECAUSE THE COMMITTEE STAFF
WHEN WE WERE. DEBATING THIS-
AND BRING THIS FORWARD IN THE
ASSEMBLY AND WE HAPPILY
ACCEPTED AMENDMENTS TO ALLOW
THE COURT TO RESTRICT THE
DRIVERS. THAT COULD LEAD TO A
DRIVER CONVICTED OF ENGAGING IN
EXPRESSION SPEED TO BE ALLOWED
TO DRIVE. THEIR VEHICLES TO AND
FROM WORK AND IT ALSO GIVES THE
COURT THE DISCRETION TO
CONSIDER ANY BURDEN HE
SUSPENDED DRIVER'S LICENSE
WOULD HAVE ONE INDIVIDUAL OR
INDIVIDUALS FAMILY AND GRANTS
ACCORD THE FLEXIBILITY. TO
ALLOW THE INDIVIDUAL TO- THE
TAKE CARE OF THEIR FAMILY DRIVE
TO WORK. BOTH BUT BOTH. BUT
BECAUSE OF THE LOOP THAT EXISTS.
SOMEONE MAY BE ABLE TO ENGAGE
IN A- IN A- SIDE SHOW. ON A AND-
HARMS THEM BY MADE IF YOU'RE
DOING IT. AND IF YOU ARE A AND
GET. THE YOU'RE- UP- HIGHWAY.
OFFERING YOUR AND YOUR JEFF-
THOSE ARE EQUALLY DANGEROUS
BEHAVIORS THAT REQUIRE- THAT
LAW ENFORCEMENT AND THAT AND-
TO HAVE SOME ADDITIONAL TOOLS.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLYMEMBER FUN
DID YOU HAVE A FOLLOW UP
SENATOR AKOWSKI ADDRESS THE
ONLY QUESTION IS THAT IF THE
SIDE SHOW IS SET UP. THERE'S
RIBBONS THERE'S BALLOONS
EVERYBODY'S THERE WERE DOING
THE SIDE SHOW BUT NOTHING. HAS
STARTED. IS THAT. A SENSIBLE
UNDER- THE V. THREE IT'S JUST
IT'S JUST THE CONGREGATION WITH
THE ANTICIPATION THAT THEY'RE
GOING TO DO THE SIDE SHOW. WITH
IS IT IS THAT. THEY'RE STANDING
THAT THAT SERVICE SO IS THIS-
IF I CAN BE RESPONDED TO SHARE
THIS A SIDE SHOW IS IT THE- THE
BEHAVIOR OF PERFORMING STUNTS
AT DANGEROUS SPEEDS THAT IS
WHAT. THE EXPRESSION SPEED IS
IT'S NOT JUST PEOPLE
CONGREGATING- AND JUST WATCHING
CARS PARKED ALONG. THE ROAD
IT'S ACTUALLY DOING DONUTS
DRIFTING- PERFORMING STUNTS- IN
VERY CLOSE PROXIMITY TO THE
CROWD IN AND WE HAVE SEEN
EXAMPLES. UNFORTUNATELY EVEN%
HERE IN SACRAMENTO WHERE CARS
HAVE LOST CONTROL AND GOING
INTO THE CROWD AND HARMED AND.
KILLED- YOUNG YOUNG INDIVIDUALS.
GREAT THANK YOU VERY MUCH SIR
MEMBER SENATOR- SENATOR SO.
THANK YOU- THIS IS A- DAVE. D.
TOWARD TO INCREASE PENALTIES
UNDER THESE KIND OF
CIRCUMSTANCES HAS. BEN
INTRODUCED NUMEROUS TIMES OVER
THE LAST COUPLE OF YEARS. AND
IN PUBLIC SAFETY ANYWAY WHILE I
WAS HERE WE DID NOT MOVE
FORWARD TO FIND THESE BILLS AND
THE REASON THAT WE DID NOT IS
BECAUSE THE DATA THAT WE HAVE
REVIEWED INDICATES THAT WHILE.
I WELL CERTAINLY THERE IS THE-
DESIRE TO INCREASE THE PENALTY
WE FOUND NO DATA TO INDICATE
THAT DOING SO REDUCE THE
BEHAVIORS SO IN OTHER WORDS IF
WE THINK ABOUT THE CONSEQUENCE
WHAT ARE WE TRYING TO DO WE'RE
TRYING TO PREVENT THE KIND OF
CIRCUMSTANCE THAT THE FAMILY
THAT WE HEARD FROM EXPERIENCE
THAT IS WHAT THAT WOULD BE
OBJECTIVE HOWEVER. THE INCREASE
OF A PENALTY OF THE SORT DOES
NOT HAVE THAT CONSEQUENCE YES
IT PENALIZES SOMEONE WHO
PARTICIPATES IN A SLIDE SHOW
MORE BUT IT DOES NOT
NECESSARILY REDUCE THE
INCIDENCE OF THEM. AND WHEN WE
THINK ABOUT THE CONSEQUENCES OF
THE- FOR EXAMPLE A LICENSE
SUSPENSION- AND THE INABILITY
THEN POTENTIALLY FOR A PERSON
TO GO TO WORK AND SUCH THERE'S
THEY CAN SPIRAL INTO MULTIPLE
OTHER IMPACTS AND THIS DOES NOT
THE THIS PARTICULAR BILL.
THERE'S WHILE WE CERTAINLY DO
NOT WANT TO HAVE ANY ANY
INJURIES OR RESULTS OR ANY HARM
TO PEOPLE BECAUSE OF ANY KIND
OF ACTIVITY LIKE THIS THIS DOES
NOT REQUIRE THAT ANYONE TO BE
HURT AND SO AGAIN. IT'S THE
CONCERN OF. SELECT DIFFERENT OR
WHO AM UP BEING AT. UNDER UNDER
INCREASING PENALTIES SO- I
APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR'S INTENT.
AND I VERY MUCH RESPECT THE-
THOSE- THE TESTIMONY WE HEARD
IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL AND
THEIR CONCERNS ABOUT THE DANGER
OF THESE BUT BECAUSE OF THE
LACK OF DATA THAT SHOWS THAT IT
WOULD ACTUALLY IMPACT THE
REDUCTION OF THESE INCIDENTS I
CAN'T SUPPORT THE BILL. THANK
YOU SENATOR SCANNER I DON'T SEE
ANY MORE UP SENATOR MELINDA'S.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR- I HAVE A
QUESTION FOR YOU IS SOME WOMEN
FIND NICE TO SEE YOU AGAIN-
YOUR BILL DOESN'T REQUIRE THAT
THE LICENSE IS SUSPENDED IT
AUTHORIZES THE REVOCATION OF IS
THAT CORRECT. YES EIGHT ALLOWS
THE COURT TO MAKE A PROPER
DECISION BASED ON THE
CIRCUMSTANCES UPON CONVICTION
NOT THE CITATION SO IF- AT
ONCE- IF I THERE'S A FORMAL
CONVICTION THE JUDGE WILL HAVE
THE ABILITY- TO- TO IT. BUT
REMOVE SOMEONE'S LICENSE BUT
WHAT WE'RE ARGUING AND WHAT
WE'RE WHAT WE'RE PROPOSING IS
NOT INCREASING PENALTIES BUT
JUST TO CREATE PARITY BETWEEN
THE TWO AT THE TWO BEHAVIORS.
RIGHT OKAY AND THAT MAKES SENSE
TO ME IT'S NOT A MANDATE IT'S
AN OPTION THAT WE WOULD LEAVE
UP TO THE DISCRETION OF THE
JUDGE FOR INSTANCE IF YOU HAVE-A CASE WHERE SOMEONE IS BEFORE
THE COURT FOR THIS VERY REASON
MULTIPLE TIMES. THEN IT WOULD
PROBABLY BE IN THE BEST
INTEREST FOR PUBLIC SAFETY FOR
A JUDGE TO REVOKE THAT LICENSE
TO KEEP THE PUBLIC SAFE- IF HE
FEELS THAT'S NECESSARY AND ARE
YOU KNOW I'M NOT I'VE NEVER
UNDERSTOOD THE. ARGUMENT THAT-
PUNISH TODAY DETER IF THAT IS
THE ARGUMENT OVER TO USE THEN
WHY. **** ANYBODY FOR ANYTHING.
IF YOU CAN'T SOLIDLY PROVE THAT
THE PUNISHMENT WILL DECREASE
THE CRIME THEN WHY IN CURSOR TO
ANYONE UNLESS THE GOAL IS TO.
NOT INCARCERATE ANYONE FOR
ANYTHING I'M NOT I'M NOT REALLY
SURE BUT I THINK THIS IS-
INTELLIGENT LEGISLATION FOR A
PROBLEM THAT. HAS COME INTO
BEING- THAT WE'VE NOT DEALT
WITH IN THE PAST SO I THINK
IT'S A GOOD PUBLIC SAFETY-
EFFORT AND CERTAINLY GOOD
TRANSPORTATION EFFORT AND SO
WITH THAT I WILL BE SUPPORTING
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR THANK YOU
SENATOR MELINDA. SENATOR DELHI.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS LIKE. I DO I'M
KIND OF BAFFLED BY THIS WAS
HAPPENING HERE WE HAVE. REASONS
FOR LOSS AND THEN WHEN PEOPLE.
THERE'S CONSEQUENCES FOR
BREAKING OFF. AND THIS IS A
COMMON SENSE APPROACH TO AN
ISSUE WHERE THE VICTIMS. IT
CONTINUES TO HAPPEN INTEL INTEL
YOU PUSH TO MAKE IT TO WHERE
THE RISK IS HIGHER THAN THE
PUNISHMENT YOU'LL CONTINUE TO
SEE WHAT WE HAVE SO I WANT TO
JUST SAY TO THE AUTHOR I
APPRECIATE YOU BRINGING THIS
BILL. THIS IS THE SECOND TIME I
BELIEVE YOU'VE- THIS BUILD OUT-
VETOED BEFORE- I WILL MOVE THE
BILL I THINK IT'S COMMON SENSE
AND I THINK IT'S THE RIGHT
THING TO DO- IN. GOOD LUCK THIS
TIME WHEN YOU GET IT TO THE
GOVERNOR. THANK YOU SENATOR
DELHI AND WE'LL GO BACK TO
SENATOR SKINNER. PRECIADO MADAM
CHAIR I WANT TO CLARIFY I AM.
AT INCHED HINDSIGHT TO MY
COMMENTS WERE NOT. A
COMPREHENSIVE ENOUGH CERTAINLY
THEIR PUNISHMENT IS APPROPRIATE
INDEPENDENT OF WHETHER IT
pDETERS CRIME SO I WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT MY COMMENTS WERE NOT
CONSTRUED THAT SOMEHOW WE
SHOULD NEVER PASS A LAW JUST
BECAUSE IT DOESN'T DETER- ON
WHAT I SHOULD HAVE SAID INSTEAD
WHICH HAS BEEN BROUGHT OUT SO
FAR IN THE TESTIMONY IS THAT WE
HAVE EXISTING LAWS. THAT MAKE
THIS A CRIME THAT HAVE
CONSEQUENCES TO THIS AND THAT-
WE'RE ON THE V. EIGHT THE STATE.
IN FACT WHAT I SHOULD HAVE SAID
THAT THIS IS SOMEONE DUPLICATE
AND WHILE THE AUTHOR'S INTENT
IS AND FEELS THERE NEEDS TO BE
AN ADDITION. IT'S THERE IS
EXISTING CODE ON THE BOOKS THAT
DOES MAKE THIS ACTIVITY ILLEGAL
WITH CONSEQUENCES. THANK YOU
SENATOR SKINNER. I DON'T SEE
ANYMORE MIKE'S UP I WILL
CONCLUDE BY SAYING- I WANT TO
THANK OU ASSEMBLYMEMBER FONG I
KNOW WE HAD A QUICK DISCUSSION
YESTERDAY AND- ALTHOUGH I'M
ALSO OF THE MINDSET I DON'T
WANT TO BE SUPER PUNITIVE ON ON
CERTAIN ISSUES AND I BELIEVE
THAT YOU KNOW WE NEED TO BE A
LITTLE BIT MORE MINDFUL IN THE
WAY WERE. ENFORCING AND HOW
WE'RE CRAFTING- PUNISHMENTS FOR
ENFORCEMENT IN IN ANY WAY I
KNOW THAT THIS IS OPTIONAL AS
YOU MENTIONED IT IS AN OPTION%
BASED ON THE DEGREE OF THAT THE
OFFENSE- BUT I'M OF THE MINDSET
TO THAT WE NEED MORE EDUCATION
OFTEN TIMES- EXHIBITION OF
SPEED GETS CLUMPED IN WITH
SPEED CONTESTS AND SO WE NEED
TO BE. VERY CLEAR ON WHAT THAT
IS AND I THINK THAT YOU'RE
DOING THIS HERE WITH THIS
LEGISLATION. AND AS WELL AS-
MORE EDUCATION TO PEOPLE NEED
TO BE EDUCATED ON EXACTLY WHAT
EXACT EXHIBITION OF SPEED IS
AND HOW NOT TO- TO CONDUCT THAT
TYPE OF BEHAVIOR- AND SO THAT
WAY WE CAN HAVE SAFER STREETS
SO WITH THAT I WANT TO SAY
THANK YOU AGAIN FOR BRINGING
THIS FORWARD AND WE WILL ALLOW
YOU TO CLOSE THE GO RED HAT. I
JUST LIKE TO THINK THAT SHE'S A
YOUTH CHAIR FOR- FOR ALLOWING
THIS BILL TO ADD TO IT TO BE
PRESENTED AND TO THAT TO THE
ROBUST CONVERSATION- CERTAINLY-
THREE RACING IN THE EXHIBITION
SPEED THE NUMBERS DON'T LIE THE
NUMBER THE MEDITATIONS THE
AMOUNT OF DEVASTATION REX
TRAGEDIES- ARE ON THE RISE AT
THEIR SURGING- AS WE'VE SEEN.
AND THIS IS A BIPARTISAN
EFFORT- THIS IS NOT SOMETHING
THAT WE TAKE LIGHTLY- WE
CERTAINLY WANT TO PROVIDE A
REASONABLE APPROACH TO
ADDRESSING THIS- THIS IS A
GROUP BUT THIS ROOM SCOURGE IN
ART AND OUR SOCIETY AND KEEPING
OUR STREETS SAFE. AND WHY THIS
BILL- IS IMPORTANT IS THAT LAW
ENFORCEMENT HAS SAID THAT THEY
DON'T HAVE THE PROPER TOOLS TO
DEAL WITH SIDE SHOWS AT THE
MOMENT AND SO THIS IS A
REASONABLE STEP FORWARD TO
ALLOW SOME DISCRETION TO CREATE
PARITY BETWEEN- SPEAK CONTESTS
AND EXHIBITIONS SPEED- WE'RE
ALSO SEEING NOW THAT CITIES
THEMSELVES. IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA OR ARE ARE GRAPPLING.
WITH THIS- THIS THIS ACTIVITY-
AND THEY'RE GOING TO. PROPOSE
AND TO PASS LOCAL. I DEAL WITH
SUCH A INTO. THIS IS NOT
SOMETHING THAT WE- IT'S GOING
AWAY. HE SOON SO WE NEED TO ACT.
AND ACT NOW AND SO I DO WANT TO
US TO THINK- YES SARAH AND HER
FAMILY WERE TRAVELING ALL THE
WAY FROM BAKERSFIELD. THE
SHARES STORY AND SO I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR NIGHT
THOUGH. THANK YOU
ASSEMBLYMEMBER AND THANK YOU TO
SARAH AS WELL- THE BOOT. THE
BILL HAS BEEN MOVED BY SENATOR
DALLY. AS MR CONSULTANT CAN YOU
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ON. THE
MOTION IS TO PASS. THE AMENDED
ON AB THREE. THE MOTION IS DUE
FOR AS A MAY. AND REFER THE
BILL TO THE PUBLIC SAFETY
COMMITTEE. CENTER ONZALEZ.
FIVE DOLLARS I BASE RIGHT. HI
HELLO. SUCH A LETTER I MARCH A
LITTLE HIGH BECKER. BECKER
CORTESE HI FORTY CI DOLLY BY
DOLLY HI DOT HI DON HI WE'RE
GOING. TO GO HIGHER I BELINDA'S
I MELINDA HIGH MAN HI MEN I TO
ME ALL RIGHT NEWMAN HI RUBIO I
BILL I SCAN. NUMBER I AM I LIKE
ASKING. BOOK I WILL I. FOURTEEN
VOTES OKAY FOR IT LOOKS LIKE
HAS ENOUGH TO GET OUT OF THE
PUT THE BALL ON THANK YOUS. BUT
THEY SAID THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT
NEXT UP IN LAST BILL WILL BE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER LUIS RIVAS AB
NINE SEVENTY FOUR. AND SHE IS
HERE WELCOME. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
REQUESTS. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS. EIGHTY NINE
SEVENTY FOUR REQUIRES MINERS TO
WEAR A HELMET WHEN RIDING A
HORSE ON PAVED HIGHWAYS AND
MANDATES THAT ALL WRITERS OR
THEIR EQUINES WEAR REFLECTIVE
GEAR OB OR LIGHTS AT SUNDOWN.
ON AN OCTOBER EVENING IN TWENTY
NINETEEN A VEHICLE STRUCK TWO
INDIVIDUALS RIDING THEIR HORSES
IN THE COMMUNITY OF LAKE VIEW
TERRACE IN THE ITY OF LOS
ANGELES WHICH IS LOCATED IN MY
DISTRICT. THIS CRASH KILLED THE
TWO HORSES AND LEFT THE TWO
RIDERS IN CRITICAL CONDITION.
MEMBERS OF MY COMMUNITY WHICH
YOU WILL HEAR FROM SHORTLY
BROUGHT THE SAFETY CONCERNS TO
MY ATTENTION AFTER RESEARCHING
THIS ISSUE WE FOUND SIMILAR
COLLISIONS IN THE COMMUNITIES
OF SAUGUS AND WILTON IN
CALIFORNIA. IT'S COMMON REPORTS
IS TO SHARE THE ROAD WITH
VEHICLES HOWEVER IT CAN BE
DIFFICULT FOR DRIVERS TO SEE
RIDERS AND THEIR HORSES IN THE
DARK. WHEN THESE COLLISIONS
OCCUR THE WRITERS ARE USUALLY
THROWN OFF OF THEIR HORSES
LEAVING THEM IN CRITICAL
CONDITION. THE HORSES USUALLY
DIE UPON COLLISION OR MUST BE
EUTHANIZED DUE TO THE INJURIES
THAT THEY SUSTAINED. EIGHTY
NINE SEVENTY FOUR IS A DIRECT
DISTRICT GENERATED PROPOSAL
THAT FURTHER PROTECTS RIDERS
AND THEIR EQUINES THROUGH
INCREASED VISIBILITY AND SAFETY
MEASURES. TODAY I HAVE WITH ME
TO PROVIDE TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT
OF THIS BILL LEADERS OF THE
EQUESTRIAN COMMUNITY IN LOS
ANGELES- I HAVE GENE A CRUISE
AND SHERRY BLOUSE. THANK YOU
ASSEMBLYMEMBER MODERATOR WE
WILL START WITH GINA CRUISE ON
THE LINE EIGHTY THIRTY NINE
CONSTITUENTS PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI CAN YOU HEAR ME YES WE CAN.
I THANK YOU- THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS- MY NAME IS
GINA CRUISE I AM FROM THE
COMMUNITY OF LAKEVIEW TERRACE
AND I'M HERE TO ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT AT EIGHTY NINE SEVENTY
FOUR. I LIVE ON A RANCH IN THE
QUESTION COMMUNITY BUSINESS
WITH URBAN AREA OF THE CITY OF
LOS ANGELES WITH MY FAMILY AND
FIVE QUARTERS. LIKE MANY
EQUESTRIANS. A MY DAUGHTER AND
I REGULARLY WRITER. ON THE
STREET. IN ORDER TO ADD. OUR
LOCAL TRAIL. IT'S VERY COMMON
TO SEE HORSES ON THE STREETS IN
MY COMMUNITY. IN FACT MANY OF
THE STREETS KNOCKING IN THE
ARCTIC. DESIGNATED A QUESTION.
WHAT WE- HAVE. IT CONTINUES
BATTLE. ON THE- IS SEPARATE A
QUESTION AND BE. OR TRAP. SO WE
SHARE THE ROAD WITH THE- NOT
TO. AGO THERE WERE THE TWO ACT.
HERE ON THE BEACH INVOLVED A
QUESTION. I AM TO BE A- AT-
NUMBER- MENTION. A COUPLE IS
WRITING A- CLICKABLE AT NIGHT
WHEN THEY WERE. FROM BY A
VEHICLE. THE WRITER CLICK
COMPANY FORCES AND WHAT THE
PURELY INJURED REQUIRING
HOSPITALS. BOTH HORSES WERE
KILLED. IF THE WRITERS HAVE
BEEN WEARING REFLECTIVE GEAR.
IT'S VERY LIKELY THAT THIS
HORRIBLE ACCIDENT COULD HAVE
BEEN AVOIDED. THIS IS NOT THE
FIRST SUCH INCIDENT THAT
HAPPENED HERE AND IT LIKELY.
WILL NOT BE THE LAST ONE
CHANGES ARE MADE. WHEN MY
DAUGHTER AND I WRITE AT NIGHT
ALWAYS WEAR A REFLECTIVE VEST.
INPUT REFLECTED ON THE HORSES.
IT REALLY IS A SMART THING TO
DO NOT ONLY FOR THE SAFETY OF
THE WRITERS AND HORSES. BUT FOR
DRIVERS AS WELL SO THEY CAN SEE
A FORMER ON THE ROAD THE BOY
COLLISIONS. FOLLOWING ON A
PAPER OKAY. YOU KNOW WHILE
ADULTS CAN MAKE THEIR OWN
DECISIONS ON THE LEVEL OF RISK
THEY WANT TO PAY. IT REALLY IS
IMPORTANT THAT CHILDREN BE
PROTECTED. BY REQUIRING A WEAR
A HELMET WHEN THEY'RE RIDING ON
THE STREET. I REALLY APPRECIATE
YOUR TIME TODAY AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE
IN FAVOR OF. EIGHTY NINE
SEVENTY FOUR TO INCREASE THE
SAFETY AND THE ABILITY. OF THE
QUESTIONS THAT HEART IS WHEN WE
SHARE THE ROAD WITH VEHICLES.
THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK YOU
MISS CRUZ FOR TESTIMONY. OUR
MODERATOR NEXT WE WILL GO TO
SHERRY BLOWS ALSO IT AT AN
ASSEMBLY DISTRICT THIRTY NINE
CONSTITUENT. HELLO THIS IS
GREAT. YES THIS IS SHERRY PLUS%
I. OF THE QUESTIONING COMMITTEE
CHAIR FOR THE ALARM
NEIGHBORHOOD COUNCIL AND A LONG
TIME FOR YOU TO READ THAN THE
BILL MARKS HOW COULD YOU EIGHTY
NINE SEVENTY FOURTH STREET IN
PORTLAND IT HELPS TO PROVIDE
SAFE PASSAGE FOR EQUESTRIAN.
COMMUNITY TO LOOK FROM THE
TRAIL. A LOT LOCAL FROM FROM
WORK AFTER FORCES AND HEAD OUT
THE TRAIL WHICH THEN MAKES
RETURNING AFTER IT'S DARK. ARE
YOU HAVE A DARK HORSE ON A DARK
PRESIDENTIAL STREET AND ITS
STRUCTURE AND- WELL WE HAVE A
PROGRAM ACCIDENTS HERE IN
BELMAR- INVOLVING DON'T FEEL
COLD AND HORSES AND THE HORSES
AND RIDERS ARE ALL WEEK
ORGANISERS. REPORTING OF THE
FACTS IS ALSO. IMPORTANT SO
IT'LL HELP US MARKET STREET
WHAT WE NEED TO PROVIDE SAFER
PASSAGE WITH PROPER SIGNAGE.
REQUIRING HELMETS FOR EIGHTEEN
AND UNDER IS REALLY A NO
BRAINER MOST WRITERS ARE A LOT
OF WRITERS ALREADY WEAR HELMET
BUT A MANDATE WOULD HELP MAKE
SURE. CHILDREN UNDER THE AGE OF.
EIGHTEEN ARE RIGHT YOU'RE GOING
TO BE EIGHTEEN. REALLY AND BILL
TO HELP US PROVIDE. THREE FOR
THE WRITERS AND FOR THE ALL
PEOPLE DRIVING HORSES ARE
DRIVING CARS BECAUSE- IT WOULD
JUST BE HORRIBLE I DON'TONE
NIGHT I WAS COMING HOME AND I
NEED TO TURN ON MY- AND- I
DIDN'T GET A BRIGHTER CUT ALL.
IF THEY HAVE REFLECTIVE GEAR
ON- IT WOULD. IT WOULD HAVE
BEEN A LOT SAFER AND I COULD
HAVE BROUGHT I COULD HAVE
STOPPED MUCH SOONER THAN THAT
IDEA. THANK YOU AND- WELL SORT
OF. TELL THANK YOU MS WELL AS
FOR TESTIMONY- SO WE'VE
CONCLUDED SUPPORT WITNESSES- ON
THE LINE SO WE'LL GO TO THE
GALLERY IF THERE'S ANYONE IN
SUPPORT OF AB NINE SEVENTY FOUR
PLEASE COME FORWARD. OKAY SEE
NONE ROOM ONE TWELVE DO WE HAVE
ANY WITNESSES IN SUPPORT THERE
C. NINE THE MODERATOR WILL TAKE
IT BACK TO YOU. FOR EIGHTY NINE
SEVENTY FOUR WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT PLEASE. AND IF YOU WANT
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF A. B.
NINE SEVENTY FOUR SLASH ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME. YEAH AND WE
HAVE NO ONE SHOWING UP AT THIS
TIME. YEAH THANK YOU OKAY WELL-
MOVE FORWARD WITH WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION AT THIS TIME I DON'T
SEE ANYONE REGISTERED IN
OPPOSITION AS A PRIMARY WITNESS
SO WE'LL SEE IF THERE'S ANYBODY
IN THE GALLERY IN OPPOSITION TO
AB NINE SEVENTY FOUR C. NINE
ANY WITNESSES IN ROOM ONE
TWELVE IN OPPOSITION CNN
MODERATOR IS THERE ANYONE IN
THE QUEUE IN OPPOSITION TO. AB
NINE SEVENTY FOUR PLEASE. IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
OF EIGHTY NINE SEVENTY FOUR
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT
THIS TIME. AND WE HAVE NO
WARNING QUEUE AT THIS TIME.
THANK YOU MR MODERATOR OKAY
WE'LL TAKE THIS BACK TO.
MEMBERS SENATOR MELINDA IS.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR- SO THE
BILL REQUIRES OF WEARING A
HELMET FOR THOSE EIGHTEEN AND
UNDER. CAN YOU EXPLAIN WHY IT'S
JUST EIGHTEEN AND UNDER BECAUSE
I PRESUME THAT IS BECAUSE OF
THE INJURY THAT CAN RESULT FROM
HITTING YOUR HEAD. NOT WEARING
HELMET WHICH I ALSO PRESUME IS
A DANGER TO- SOMEONE OF ANY AGE
NOT JUST EIGHTEEN AND UNDER SO
I JUST WARNING IF YOU COULD
FURTHER EXPAND ON WHY IT'S ONLY
EIGHTEEN AND UNDER- NO I A. I
UNDERSTAND YOUR CONCERN AND-
FOR THIS BILL WE FOCUSED. ON
MINORS- BECAUSE LIKE OF ONE OF
MY WITNESSES TESTIFIED WE
BELIEVE ADULTS CAN MAKE THEIR
DECISIONS AND WE HAVE A LOT OF
ADULTS THAT ARE. EQUESTRIAN
RIDERS THAT DO WEAR HELMETS- ON
THEM YOU KNOW THEY THEY MAKE
THAT DECISION- BUT WE WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT MINERS ARE SAFE.
BUT I AGREE I BELIEVE EVERYONE
SHOULD WEAR A HELMET. OKAY I
JUST. AND I APPRECIATE YOUR-
CLARIFICATION AND I RECOGNIZE
THAT THE BILL IS FOCUSING ON
MINORS I GUESS I JUST DON'T
UNDERSTAND WHY IF IT'S IF IT'S
FOR THE PURPOSES OF SAFETY I'M
AN ADULT WHO FALLS AND HITS
THEIR HEAD IS JUST AS MUCH AS
RISK AS SOMEONE WHO IS
SEVENTEEN- SO- BUT THANK YOU
FOR THE CLARIFICATION. THANK
YOU SENATOR MELINDA IS ARE
THERE ANY OTHER MIKES UP I SEE
NONE. OKAY I WANNA THANK YOU
ASSEMBLYMEMBER REVISE FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD I KNOW
THIS CAME DIRECTLY FROM YOUR
CONSTITUENTS BACK HOME AS WE'VE
HEARD- MEMBERS OF THE QUESTION
COMMUNITY. I WANT TO THAN THEM
FOR BEING ON THE LINE AS WELL
AND I KNOW THIS IS VERY
IMPORTANT TO YOU- SO WITH THAT
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE PLEASE-
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR- I ALSO
WANT TO THANK. THE MEMBERS OF
THE EQUESTRIAN COMMUNITY IN MY
DISTRICT- THIS BILL WAS THEIR
IDEA THEY CAME TO ME THEY THEY
HAVE WORKED WITH US ALL ALONG.
AND IT'S BECAUSE OF THEM THAT
WE'VE REACHED ON THE SENATE AND
WE HOPE TO MAKE IT TO THE
GOVERNOR'S DESK BUT FOR NOW I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
VOTE. THANK YOU ASSEMBLYMEMBER
END- SENATORS WHILE WE'RE
TAKING THE VOTE CAN ENSURE THAT
EVERYONE SPEAKS IN THERE MIKE-
JUST SO WE CAN HEAR- YOUR- I OR
NO BOAT. THANK YOU ALRIGHT WITH
THAT WE WILL GO AHEAD AND TAKE
A MOTION ON AB NINE SEVENTY
FOUR THE MOTION THANK YOU
SENATOR TO LEAD ACTORS MOTIONS
SO MR CONSULTANT CAN YOU PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AND WE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON JUDICIARY.
SENATOR'S OFFICE HI GOOD
DOLLARS FIVE BATES ABILITY.
ALAN HI ELLEN HI MARCH ELEVENTH
I WATCH A LITTLE HI BECKER IN
THE HIGH TECH- BY CORTESE HI
WHAT DCI DALI. DALI HI DOT. HI
DON HI WHERE. IT'S VERY
SPECIFIC TALKING. HI WIRE I
THINK IN. MELINDA'S HI
MELINDA'S I MEN HI MAN HI
NEWMAN HI NEWMAN HI RUBIO. I
RUBIO HI SKINNER HI SKINNER BY
NUMBER I AM BERG I LIKE
HOUSEKEEPING HI WHAT CASKEY HI
WILL I WILL I. SIXTEEN VOTES
OKAY THANK YOU A SIMILAR MEMORY
OF US IT LOOKS LIKE IT HAS
ENOUGH TO GET OUT AND WE WILL
PUT THE BALL FELL ON CALL I
THINK WE'RE WAITING FOR ONE
OTHER MEMBER. THANK YOU THANK
YOU. GREAT SO MISTER CONSULTANT
I THINK WE'VE CONCLUDED OUR
AGENDA FOR THE TIME BEING BUT
WE'LL GO BACK TO BILLS THAT ARE
ON CALL CURRENTLY- SO WE'LL
START WITH AB THREE
ASSEMBLYMEMBER FONG. EIGHTY
THREE THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED AND REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON PUBLIC SAFETY THE
CHAIR AND THE VICE CHAIR BOLD
VOTING HI. ALAN. SKINNER.
SKINNER HI QUITE HEALTHY. HEY
HI MY PESKY. SIXTEEN ZERO I
THINK IT'S GREAT THANK YOU THAT
BILL GETS OUT- LET'S GO AHEAD
AND TAKE THE FINAL ITEM SEVEN
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LUIS RIVAS
EIGHTY NINE SEVENTY FOUR AGAIN
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AND
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
JUDICIARY. BATES. SIXTEEN ZERO.
THANK YOU OKAY AND THEN WE'LL
GO AHEAD AND TAKE ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR I THINK WE HAD
A MISSING MEMBER ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR CONSISTING OF A B. TWO
THIRTY TWO EIGHTY THREE OF TWO.
EIGHTY FIVE NINE ONE A. B.
SEVEN A. FOUR. A. B. SEVEN NINE
EIGHT. AB ONE ONE FIVE SEVEN
TERABYTES YOU'RE VOTING I HELEN
HI ELLEN HI. DOT DOT HI
BELINDA'S. I LINDOS HI SKINNER.
SKINNER HI SEVENTEEN VOTES
GREAT THE CONSENT CALENDAR HAS
BEEN APPROVED SO WE'LL GO BACK
TO FILE ITEM ONE EIGHTY THREE
FOR ABSENT MEMBERS PLEASE. A.
B. THREE THE MOTION IS TO PASS
AS AMENDED AND REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON PUBLIC SAFETY
HELEN HI HELEN HI. SEVENTEEN
VOTES. OKAY THANK YOU THAT BILL
IS OUT ALL RIGHT SO THANK YOU
ALL TO ALL INDIVIDUALS WHO
PARTICIPATED IN PUBLIC
TESTIMONY TODAY IF YOU WERE NOT
ABLE TO TESTIFY PLEASE SUBMIT
YOUR COMMENTS OR SUGGESTIONS IN
WRITING TO THE TRANSPORTATION
COMMITTEE OR VISIT OUR WEBSITE
YOUR COMMENTS AND SUGGESTIONS
ARE ALWAYS IMPORTANT TO US WE
WANT TO THANK EVERYONE FOR
THEIR PATIENCE AND CORPORATIONS
WE HAVE CONCLUDED THE AGENDA
AND THE SENATE COMMITTEE ON
TRANSPORTATION IS ADJOURNED
THANK YOU MEMBERS.